il n'y aura pas de duel télévisé entre
jean marie le pen est jacques chirac le
président sortant l'a refusée ce qui a
provoqué aussitôt une réaction virulente
de son compétiteur charles sanviti une
entorse à la coutume républicaine pour
la première fois depuis 1974
le duel cathodique de l'entre-deux tours
n'aura pas lieu
ce combat souvent sanctionnés par un ko
le président candidat n'en veut pas la
politique du spectacle
ça n'est pas pour lui question de forme
les questions de fond pas plus que je
n'ai accepté dans le passé d'alliance
avec le front national
et ceci quel qu'en soit le prix
politique
pas plus que je ne les accepte et dans
le passé je n'accepterai demain de thé
pas avec son représentant
je ne peux pas accepter la banalisation
de l'intolérance et de la haine
l'intolérance et la haine pour ligne de
démarcation
voilà les mots du président candidat une
ligne de partage récusé par jean marie
le pen à l'aise aux jeux du cirque et
dans la fosse aux lions c'est une
pitoyable dégonfle had moi je lui
offrais un duel et quand on a un
adversaire d'un duel est considérée
comme s'étant retiré il est déshonoré
sont les règles de l'honneur une matière
que connaît mal jacques chirac alors
duels et non pas de débat décidément en
politique
les deux capitaines à l'évidence ne
tiennent pas le même cap